BRIAN: I WOULD SAY IT'S THE MOST
WATCHED SENATE RACE IN THE
COUNTRY.
ELECTION DAY IS THREE DAYS AWAY.
MOST OF THE MEDIA IS VERY
WORRIED.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
PENNSYLVANIA WHERE DR. MEHMET OZ
IS LEADING JOHN FETTERMAN FOR
THE FIRST TIME.
THE MEDIA IS GOING CRAZY WITH A
SHAMELESS CAMPAIGN IN MY VIEW TO
BOOST FETTERMAN.
THE LATEST IS TO ATTACK DR. OZ
AS A DOCTOR.
>> HE'S A QUACK DOCTOR THAT MADE
HIS RICHES THAT WAY.
>> IT'S UNBECOMING OF A DOCTOR.
>> LET'S PUT DOCTOR IN QUOTES
FOR DR. OZ.
>> OZ IS VERY SLICK.
DON'T VOTE FOR ME FOR POLITICS.
BRIAN: OR ANYTHING.
THE DOCTOR RUNNING FOR
PENNSYLVANIA SENATOR IS WITH US
NOW.
PEOPLE COULD INSULT YOU OR NOT
VOTE FOR YOU.
BUT COULD YOU LET EVERYBODY KNOW
YOUR MEDICAL CREDENTIALS?
>> I WAS WELL TRAINED.
I INVENTED LIFE-SAVING DEVICES
TO FIX HEART VALVES.
I'M A PROFESSOR AT A MAJOR
UNIVERSITY.
I HAVE DONE ALL THE THINGS YOU
WANT TO DO IN MEDICINE.
I LOVE MEDICINE, IT'S MY
CALLING.
BUT I UNDERSTAND THERE ARE
BIGGER CHALLENGES FACING OUR
COUNTRY.
JUST LIKE I DID IN MY PRACTICE
TO EMPOWER MY PATIENTS, I WANT
TO DO THE SAME FOR VOTERS.
AND I'M LISTENING TO UNDERSTAND
THE CHALLENGES.
THE GOOD NEWS IS PEOPLE ARE
OPTIMISTIC.
THEY KNOW WE CAN FIX THE
PROBLEMS.
THE BAD NEWS IS WE HAVE SENIORS
WHO KNOW THEIR SOCIAL SECURITY
CHECKS WON'T STRETCH FAR ENOUGH.
WE HAVE YOUNG COUPLES WHO KNOW
THEY CAN'T AFFORD TO BUY A
HOUSE.
WE ARE WORRIED ABOUT FENTANYL
COMING IN THE MAILBOX.
EVERY STATE IS A BORDER STATE.
I THINK WE HAVE YOU KITCHEN
TABLE ISSUES PEOPLE ARE WORRIED
ABOUT.
BUT IF WE GET THE RIGHT PEOPLE
IN OFFICE WE CAN DEAL WITH THE
PROBLEM.
MY OPPONENT JOHN FETTERMAN LIKES
EXTREME IDEAS AND HE WILL BRING
THOSE BAD IDEAS TO WASHINGTON TO
HURT ALL OF US.
BRIAN: PEOPLE KNOW YOU BECAUSE
YOU WERE A GUEST ON OPRAH.
YOU WERE SO GOOD OPRAH SAID I
WANT TO SYNDICATE YOU.
YOU WOULD DROP BY "FOX AND
FRIENDS" BEFORE YOU DID YOUR
SHOW.
ALTHOUGH YOU MENTIONED TO ME YOU
ASKED HER TO STAY ON THE
SIDELINES, SHE DECIDED TO GET
OFF THE SIDELINES.
HERE IS WHO SHE IS ENDORSING TO
BE THE NEXT SENATOR OF
PENNSYLVANIA.
>> IT'S UP TO THE CITIZENS OF
PENNSYLVANIA, BUT I WILL TELL
YOU IF I ALREADY LIVED IN
PENNSYLVANIA I WOULD HAVE CAST
MY VOTE FOR JOHN FETTERMAN FOR
MANY REASONS.
BRIAN: DOES THAT BOTHER YOU?
>> NO, I LOVE OPRAH.
YOUR NEIGHBORS HAVE DIFFERENT
POLITICAL VIEWS THAN YOU DO.
BUT YOU GET TO TALK TO YOUR
NEIGHBORS AND WORK THINGS OUT.
FAMILIES ARE HOOKING TO US FOR
LEADERSHIP.
WHEN I WAS A LITTLE BOY MY
FATHER TOLD US WE WOULD BE
REPUBLICANS.
HE WAS AN IMMIGRANT WHO GREW UP
ON A DIRT FLOOR.
HE SAID REPUBLICANS HAD BETTER
IDEAS.
WITH ALL THE SUPPORT FETTERMAN
IS GETTING, ESPECIALLY HIS
MONETARY SUPPORT, WE ARE STILL
KEEPING UP WITH HIM.
WE HAVE DONE AN AGGRESSIVE JOB
GETTING THE RIGHT STORY OUT.
BUT I'M NOT A POLITICIAN.
I'M A HEART DOCTOR, AND WE FOCUS
ON BIG ISSUES.
WE UNITE PEOPLE TO FIX THOSE
PROBLEMS.
WE CAN'T TAKE ON THE BIGGER
CHALLENGES AND OUR ADVERSARIES
OVERSEAS.
THE QUESTION IS ARE YOU HAPPY
WHERE THE COUNTRY IS HEADED?
PEOPLE USUALLY SAY NO, AND I
BELIEVE IN THE LAND